in the years since the Harry Potter film
franchise wrapped up its cast members
have gone on to plenty of new projects
finding fresh opportunities beyond the
world of witches and wizards and outside
the hallowed halls of Hogwarts and that
includes Eve Anna Lynch who brought Luna
Lovegood to life when she joined the
film series in its fifth installment
Harry Potter and the order of the
Phoenix flinch may have been a late
comer to the massive Potter franchise
but she was a very welcome addition the
Irish actress who grew up reading the
Harry Potter books added whimsy and
heart to the films as Luna an
intelligent and eccentric ravenclaw
student who believes in some of the
weirdest magical theories around as a
part of Harry's core group Luna fights
alongside him and his friends at the end
of order of the Phoenix as they face off
against evil Death Eaters she more than
proved her worth in the 5th harry potter
flick and from that point on Luna is an
integral part of the plot and Lynch
became an integral part of the franchise
behind the scenes as well right from the
moment she went to an open casting call
for the role in 2006 Lynch was already a
huge fan of the books and films and had
even sent letters to Harry Potter author
JK Rowling well before she became a part
of the franchise she told Lorraine Kelly
say I wrote her and she wrote back and
we became friends and we became well pen
friends before I got the role though she
had been in contact with Rowling prior
to auditioning Lynch won the coveted
role of Luna fair and square
beating out a reported 15 thousand other
young girls who auditioned to play Luna
and impressing during her screen test
with Radcliffe Lynch was practically
born to play the bright-eyed Witch and
the minds behind the film nuit producer
David Heyman even said the others could
play Luna Amana Lynch is Luna Rowling
has also admitted that as she finished
the final books in the Harry Potter
novel series she envisioned Lynch while
writing Luna seems flinch clearly tasted
the sweetness of success during her
years longed for movie turn as Luna
Lovegood
and luckily for the talented actress
she's continued landing roles after the
Harry Potter franchise ended in 2011
both in film and on the stage the
actress has booked a number of roles in
live theatre appearing as Luna Lovegood
in 2012 a very potter senior year as
Bessie Dini and Peter sneeze 2013
production Houdini as runt in the
2017-2018 stage adaptation of the irish
film disco pigs as gaby in 2019
the omission of the family Coleman and
as Martha and director Anthony Banks's
games for lovers on the film side of
things Lynch moved away from
blockbusters after Harry Potter ended
and appeared in several smaller films
including my name is Emily GBF and the
British television movie Danny and the
human Zoo
Lynch also played Teresa Bornstein in
the true-life film dynamite a cautionary
tale and had a cameo role and Jason uses
madness in the method Lynch's after
Potter adventures also took her to the
small screen she's popped up on an
episode of the action-adventure series
Sinbad as well as on the pilot episode
of apex the actress also lent her voice
to three different characters Academy
Voice tablet and lunchbox a Nickelodeon
animated Nicktoons middle school moguls
Lynch's highest profile turn since
playing Luna Lovegood came during her
time across the pond on the 27th season
of ABC's Dancing with the Stars along
with her dance partner Keough motes fa
she ultimately finished the competition
in third place beyond her professional
life Lynch has also maintained a
personal brand dedicated to health and
wellness openly discussing her struggles
with eating disorders and becoming an
advocate for body positivity I was
battling an eating disorder anyone knew
that I needed to sort of know is it
completely he takes over your life and
the only thing that could actually take
my attention apart from that was the
Harry Potter series and she's also a
vegan activist even co-founding a vegan
beauty box with fellow actress and
activist daniella monet after seeing
Lynch come of age on the big screen it's
gratifying for fans to know that she
continues to thrive the actress clearly
has a bright future ahead of her between
her stage work film career and activism
though the Potter series is over it's
obvious that Lynch is here to stay check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]